ann reardon of how to cook that points
out that lots of people have probably
hurt themselves because of
stupid viral cooking videos and she
asked the question could they sue the
platform or not this is a great question
and one of the few times when i can
confidently say that there is an answer
at least in the united states there's
two reasons why youtube won't be liable
for
people posting really stupid content one
is the terms of service you know that
contract that you didn't read when you
signed up for youtube that basically
absolves youtube of all liability
related to
the videos and the second reason is that
infamous section 230 of the
communications
decency act which provides some
protection for website operators and
platforms specifically section 230
prevents a website or
a platform like youtube or anyone else
from having liability for
content posted by somebody else and
that's probably a good thing because if
youtube was responsible for every stupid
thing that a user posted well
there probably wouldn't be too many
users on youtube so no youtube
isn't liable but theoretically those
individual users could be so maybe we'll
see them
in court